un passage à tabac d'un homme noir aux
mains de quatre policiers
le violent démantèlement d'un camp de
migrants des manifestations pour la
liberté de presse qui tourne au cou t5
brutale en rafales et elles ont choqué
ces images mais ont-elles sûr j'aimerais
bien dire oui les images sont choquantes
mais non malheureusement on est on est
habitué les personnages ils sont
habitués aux agences policières depuis
longtemps juste saisi le ministre de
l'intérieur a rapidement demandé à
l'inspection générale de la police
nationale la police des polices d'ouvrir
une enquête
mais les conclusions de cette enquête
n'était pas encore connu qu'une autre
vidéo est venue de l'aveu même du
président emmanuel macron couvrir de
honte les forces policières
filmé par une caméra de surveillance la
vidéo montre un homme noir
michel est clair producteur de musique à
paris ou et de coups par des policiers
alors qu'il se trouve dans l'entrée d'un
studio de musique
j'ai peur les gens qui doit me protéger
me braque
moi j'ai rien fait pour mériter ça et je
juste que ces trois personnes là soient
punis par la loi les quatre policiers
impliqués dans la sphère ont été
suspendues à la demande du ministre de
l'intérieur et placé en garde à vue dans
le cadre d'une enquête pour violences
volontaires par personne dépositaire de
l'autorité publique et faux en écriture
publique
deux de ces policiers sont derrière les
barreaux pour éviter un risque qu'il ne
se concerte une fasse pression sur les
témoins
une réponse d'une rare fermeté que l'on
doit à la seule existence de la vidéo
croit l'avocat militants des droits de
l'homme henri leclerc l'avocat que je
suis peux vous dire que nous en avons
des récits de ce type mais nous ne
pouvons pas prouver pourquoi parce qu'en
général les gens sont poursuivis pour
violences agents 3 jure violence et nous
n'avons pas images et quand nous disons
mais non c'est les policiers qui nous
ont battus nous n'avons aucun moyen de
preuve quand il n'y a pas de témoins ces
images accablantes surviennent alors que
le gouvernement est plongé dans une
polémique autour d'une proposition de
loi sur la sécurité globale
un des articles de cette loi en
particulier l'article 24 suscite la
controverse
le texte prévoit de pénaliser la
diffusion malveillantes d'image des
forces de l'ordre l'intention c'est de
protéger les policiers martel des
auteurs de la loi
ses opposants eu des nonces une atteinte
à la liberté de presse et évoque le
soupçon d'un gouvernement qui cherche à
masquer les violences policières
samedi dernier ils sont descendus en
masse dans les rues de france
une mobilisation d'ampleur qui habite
dégénéré en affrontements entre les
policiers dont 23 ont été blessés une
minorité de manifestants
son appareil photo viennent en évidence
n'a pas empêché amiral habib un
photographe de presse de recevoir un
coup de matraque d'un policier au visage
le jeune syrien à documenter les
horreurs de la guerre à alep et la
violence mais c'est être derrière lui en
trouvant refuge en france croyait-il je
vois l'aveyron ce même pour moi
personnellement comme jeter en serre est
toujours en vie il aurait fait pas
comprendre que
puis d'autres ça sert un mois en france
apparaît donc c'est pour moi que c'est à
la gare je photographie et tous donc
s'il n'attendait pas enfin et c on a en
france une inspection générale de la
police nationale qui contrôle la police
tire la police se contrôler elle même
c'est une une
une exception dans les polices
européennes et donc du coup c'est à dire
que là quand quelqu'un a un problème
avec la police
il va voir la police qui est sous les
ordres du ministre et si jamais ça met
en cause un commissaire un préfet ou le
ministre évidemment l'enquète va vite
est orienté ou enterrés donc en fait il
ya ce côté qui était impossible et donc
la loi sécurité globale a rajouté le
fait qu'on ne peut plus filmer les
policiers ou alors si en prenant des
risques
résultat des courses cirque le seul
dernier moyen de preuve de montrer ce
qui se passait en interne ne sera plus
possible
il est là le coeur du problème croît ce
policier des services de renseignement
aujourd'hui il se croit forcé de quitter
la police est de vider son sac
convaincu qu'il est impossible de
changer de l'intérieur une organisation
qui est à refaire on est lâché par la
population à ce qu'on nous fait faire
des choses contre nature on est lâché
par notre hiérarchie mais ça ça fait des
années j'en veux pour exemple de le
dernier en date la loi sécurité globale
ils disent que c'est pour notre
protection que les gens n'auront plus
droit de nous filmer avec quelque chose
on est dans minority report parce qu'on
ne peut pas connaître les intentions des
gens moment il nous filme il proposait
un an de prison
voilà mais des lois existent déjà cela
ne tienne
l'article 24 tant décrié se rate
entièrement réécrit mais pas question
pour le gouvernement de l'abandonner